the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode
hey good morning everybody it's uh
thursday july
15th 2021 and you know thanks for taking
the time out to come to this
presentation
my name is michael baltos i'm the
founder and trader at orderflows.com
and today i'll be talking about how to
profit from
order flow you know order flow is
is something that not a lot of traders
right now
really understand you know but it's a
great tool for
uh pretty much anybody that's you know
involved in the markets to understand
what's really happening in the market
so what we'll be covering today is how
to get the most from
order flow how to see market nuances in
the order flow
and how to discover trading
opportunities other traders
miss okay and my goal is to show you how
to use
the freshest market generated
information based on what is trading
right now
in the market so you're ahead of all the
other traders out there
and you know what that really means is
you're making
trading decisions based on what's
being traded right now you know it's not
based on
a moving average or v web you know
taking into account
everything that's traded um you know
over the last
hour or the last week or anything like
that you're you're making your trading
decisions based on
the freshest best information
available you know it's like um
you know i i live in the midwest of the
united states
and you know the price of gas everywhere
has been going up
and i know that you know when it's time
to buy gas you know i need to know
where the least expensive gas is
available
right and it's based on what the price
of gas is right now not what it was a
week ago
and you know so i know where i'm going
to go to get gas because you know it's a
big difference
for you know um i can go to a gas
station it's only 309
versus another gas station where it's
343. you know and i fill out my car 15
gallons
you know i'll say that's a lot of money
but you know it's seven eight dollars
and you're doing it twice a week
you know that's that's fifteen twenty
two you know fifteen dollars
times how many cars over you know the
course of
a month over the course of a year it
really starts to add up and that's
really what order flow is about right
it's based about what's trading
um right now and how to how to get the
most out of that information
now order flow is not the latest
greatest fad in trading you know a lot
of people
they'll say oh you know order flows it's
just uh it's just a fad
you know people you know it's a buzz
word it's it's really not
you know one of the greatest books on
trading that's available out there
is reminiscence of a stock operator
right and it's about
um the trader back in the 1920s well he
was an order flow trader you know and
that's a hundred years ago so you could
imagine you know
you know how people have used order flow
for the at least a century
okay and and even longer so
the training today is for serious
traders that want to understand
what's actually happening in the market
right because you know as a trader you
don't want to just be blindly taking
buys and and cells because you know your
system says buy and sell no you want to
understand
why the market is acting the way it is
and that's how order flow is going to
help you
now let me just you know preface this
before we go
really deep into order flows it's not
about finding every turning point in the
market before it happens right it's
about reading the market
to find the opportunities that are so
obvious that the trade is about as close
to a sure thing
as possible now there are no sure things
in trading or
in life but you see occurrences you see
activity happening in the market
that have a very strong
probability of continuing right
it's it's basically what people are
doing right now
and you know people will do the same
thing over and over
until they change their behavior and do
something else and you know as a trader
you want to take advantage of that
and traders who are unfamiliar with
order flow think it's just a tool for
traders right like oh you know like
you know macd is a tool or rsi you know
a lot of these indicators are just tools
right but it's not right
really order flow is a whole tool set
right the market is full of a lot of
different nuances
and having just one tool isn't going to
help you very much
when the conditions in the market change
because if you just have a screwdriver
but you're trying to bang in a nail that
screwdriver is not going to help you
right so it's not one tool it's really a
combination
of tools that is going to help you
understand what's happening in the
market
i mean you know you can't loosen a bolt
with a hammer i mean you can bang on it
all you want but it's really not going
to do much
so why would you analyze the market with
a particular tool
when that tool is only useful for
certain market conditions
right you may have a great indicator but
it only works in trending markets well
what's going to happen
when you know the market is
consolidating well
it's not going to be very effective
right you can't use the same tool
in all market conditions right you're
going to
you're going to have periods where it
works fantastic you're going to have
periods where it struggles right and as
a trader
you really want to understand what's
happening in the market now
i have a special bonus for those that
stick around
and you know are interested in order
flow right if you stick around to the
end
it's you'll get a copy of the book that
i wrote on order flow it's called
trading order flow and it's 150 page
book you're not going to get a hardcover
copy you'll just get
access to the download 150 page pdf
okay and really you know this is in my
opinion
an obs uh webinar right because you know
i want you to really understand the
power of order flow
so order flow gets you as close to
as gets you as close as possible to
what's happening in the market
right you want to be base your trades
off of
what's happening right now and you know
really what that means is you know in
the old days when there was
trading floor right like the cme and
cbot
you know people paid hundreds of
thousands of dollars to be on the floor
to be a local to see
the flow of orders coming in and trade
against it you know and they made
a lot of money those guys right that but
they paid a lot of money to get access
to that
information and you know as traders now
right the the barrier of entry has
decreased dramatically
and the exchange puts out all that
information to a trader
so if you're not using that information
you're really leaving a lot on the table
now order flow also allows you to gauge
the tendency a market will continue in a
direction
right the new trading activity which is
the volume is what's going to keep the
markets moving
in that direction right you know the
laws of physics you know an object in
motion will stay in motion until it
meets an opposing force you know the
same thing is is
happening in the market all right a
trend will continue
until it ends until it reaches an
opposing force you know a trend up will
continue until it reaches resistance
right and then will often reverse and
as an order flow trader you're going to
have better more complete information
than
99 of the traders out there who are only
looking at open
high low close and maybe volume at
times right so you can see what other
traders are not paying attention to
so those of you just really briefly that
are new to my presentations
who am i right why should you listen to
me okay i mean there's a lot of people
out there
that you know are putting themselves out
oh you know
i'll teach you how to trade et cetera et
cetera well i've been a trader i've been
a trader for
since the 1990s okay uh at a
professional level i'm not talking about
someone you know
trading um you know my own small account
you know i traded
i started on the cme floor as a runner
right that's where you started
back in the days you know when there was
a floor when there was open outcry you
started that's the bottom
okay then eventually i worked my way up
you know i left the floor when
electronic trading
started taking off and i worked on the
trading desk at dean witter
overnight trading globex whether that
was the cme project a
was cbot and nymex access as well as all
the other exchanges
after dean witter i joined the global
macro futures trading desk at edf man
the big
english trading company they had office
in chicago and
you know i spent a couple years there
after that i joined commerce bank
right the what used to be about the
second biggest bank in
in germany behind deutsche bank um as
their licensed urex
trader right i was one of only a handful
of people that were
able to trade bones bobble and shots in
the us
on the on the trading terminal and after
that i joined cargill
and became eventually the head of the
futures trading desk
and they sent me out to singapore to set
up a trading desk even when um
the pit closed on in singapore on symex
right because we needed a trading desk
off the floor and after that i joined
jp morgan i spent eight years at jp
morgan vice president of futures trading
then after you know i got married and we
had our first daughter i
i just couldn't take the corporate world
anymore
and i left and i started up order
flows.com i started writing my book
and we released software okay it's the
order flows trader
3.0 now for it and it works on a
ninjatrader eight right the reason it
was called
order flows trader 3.0 is because we've
done already three major upgrades
we're on the third major upgrade
actually and
the reason i talk about this is because
you know the charts you see in this
presentation are generated from the
order flows trader
software okay so again
i want you to see how easily and quickly
you can apply order flow analysis to
your trading
right so you can make better more
informed trades
now before we really dive in just brief
disclaimer trading involves risk right
risk capital is money that should not be
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
right only risk capital should be used
for trading and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading
just basically you know don't trade with
your rent money right i i know
you know when when kobet hit you know
people really started
trading right stocks cryptos everything
and you know a lot of times you know
there's people like well i got no more
job
and it's sort of like a race against
time okay don't put yourself in that
position
you know scared money is basically lost
money
you know be comfortable where you are
financially
before you start trading because you
don't want to have that extra burden on
you
and you know it's just not a good thing
to
get into when you start trading so
before we begin you know i want you to
understand where order flow comes from
right and if you look at a normal bar
chart right
have you ever really thought about where
the information from the chart comes
from right you see the bars right the
open
you know the highs the lows where it
closes right bar was up or down
you know where the candle was red or
green well it comes from
the time and sales okay now most traders
think
of order flow being the dome right this
one here on
the right right which shows the best
bids and best offers well that's working
orders
okay yes technically you know you could
make an argument that well you know the
dome is really the order flow well
yeah it's orders but they're not being
executed
okay a lot of times you know people put
bids in pull it people
work offers they pull it as the market
starts getting closer right it's one of
those things where
you know the market is 30 not trading 39
you know yeah i'd be
i'd love to sell it at 41 but when it's
trading 39
but the problem is as it starts going up
there all of a sudden you know selling
at 41 doesn't look so good
people start pulling their offers okay
so
the order book is constantly changing
really what you want to be
focusing on is what's actually traded in
the market
right what's you know people's
commitment you know when you person gets
into a trade
and they're in a position well at some
point they're gonna have to get out of
that position either they're gonna
make money or they're gonna be losing
money okay so if
they're losing money you know it's sort
of i don't say clouds their perception
but you know it makes them
think again on you know really where
they're going to get out at
you know at the least amount of uh
loss or preferably the most amount of
profit
now the problem with time and sales as
well as the dome right the depth of
market is just moves too fast
it's very difficult to understand now if
you've ever been to a car race you know
formula one
and you know you're there with your
iphone trying to take a picture of the
car the cars move so fast you can't take
a picture
and that's what looking at the time and
sales is like it moves so fast you can't
take a picture
right even the depth of market for
many markets you know e-mini's nasdaq it
really moves too fast for you to really
get a handle
you know some markets that move slower
you know which is easier to deal with
you know if you're doing trading
um treasuries or even
currencies and obviously the grains it's
more manageable but if you're trading
something like
um nasdaq and even a certain extent s ps
e-minis it's it just moves too fast you
can't really make
good trading decisions right you just
you just can't right and the way i
describe it is it's like watching a
formula one right you just
you see the cars you know if you're way
up in the stands you see the cars on the
track but you know if you're up close
and you're trying to take a picture you
can't right
so what's the difference between time
and sales and a bar chart well a bar
chart just shows the prices
that are traded right it leads the
trader to believe that all prices are
equal
when in reality not all prices are equal
right not
every trade that happens is the same and
if you're looking at a bar chart
you don't know that it traded just you
know if it traded just
one contract at 41 or if it traded 5 000
contracts at 41.
okay so whether it trades one or five
thousand
it doesn't matter to you if you're
looking at a bar chart or a candlestick
chart you just see oil traded 41
whereas you know time and sales is going
to show you the price that traded
and the volume that traded and what a
lot of people don't realize it also
shows you
the side of the market that it traded so
what that means is if
there's a big offer okay say there's 5
000 on the offer at 41
and someone just comes in and buys it
buys all 5 000
right if you're looking at a normal bar
chart you'll just see oh 41 is traded
but if you're looking at time and sales
right you'll see wow 5 000 traded
you had someone just aggressively go in
and buy
5 000 contracts now as a trader that's
very important information you know
something
that you can use for you know in your
trading analysis right because if
normally
200 contracts trade but all of a sudden
someone just stepped right up and bought
five thousand you know it's going to
make you think
okay why are they buying five thousand
maybe they know something maybe
not but you know it leads you to the
next step in your analysis
so what exactly is order flow and why is
it important to traders
well most traders like i said just look
at a market
almost you know two dimensional right
you just see
okay well it traded 39 and a half the
low is you know 38 and three quarters
and we closed at 39 and a quarter okay
but order flow traders will see well
okay
it's you know the most of the volume
occurred at 39 and a quarter
you know it did trade up to 39 and a
half there's some decent volume
but at 38th and three quarters it only
traded eight contracts
okay so it's very light so you know you
can take a step further and what that
means you know when you see well it only
traded eight contracts
so it's telling you not a lot of selling
interest down here
right much more interest sort of mid bar
right which is where it should be this
is sort of a normal bar but if you're
looking at
a normal candlestick chart you can't
make that uh differentiation
right you can't see that volume and
the information that you see on your bar
chart
is comes from the time and sales right
but again it leaves out the most
important piece of information which is
volume
and more importantly not just volume but
the volume that traded on the bid
and the volume that's traded on the
offer
you know if you're looking at this chart
right you'd be wondering okay well
what are we going to do right market
sold off so we're just going sideways
you know it looks like we're going to
start to rally but you know are we or
we're just still going sideways or are
we going to sell off again
it's you know it's very difficult to
make a solid trading decision
but if you're looking at the order flow
well you can see a lot of information
beyond just where the price where the
market opened and closed in a bar
now you're seeing um you know the
aggressiveness of traders either
aggressive buying or aggressive selling
you know what's volume is doing in a bar
you know is
the volume in a bar migrating higher or
migrating lower
you know when you think of volume you
start to think of value right where the
most
volume traded is generally going to be
where
everybody is happy to transact right and
that sort of translates
loosely into value right and in a bar
on a bar by bar basis if the level where
most people are happy to transact starts
moving higher
over bar over next bar over an x bar
that means
you know people are accepting higher
prices and are happy to take the market
higher
so he has a plethora of information
on a normal order flow chart
okay so while an order flow chart looks
complicated it's really not
right and you know i was having this
conversation earlier with anna about
driving
it's when most of us had learned to
drive we've had no experience
right i when i learned to drive the only
experience i had driving was driving a
tractor
okay and it's very similar but
obviously you know in a tractor if it
bangs into something it's not going to
kill you but you know in a car
you crash into a light pole it's a
chance you get killed um
but once we started driving you know we
really became
comfortable with it right now we're all
good drivers you know we can sense that
you know we're driving down the road we
know there's a car in front of us to the
left car to the right
you know a car in our you know in our
behind us
so we we you know we're internalizing
everything that's happening
and it's the same with order flow when
someone comes
first to order flow and looks at a
footprint chart they think my god what
is this mess you only see a lot of
numbers and they're scared
but once they understand it trading
becomes
easier for them right and you know the
way i describe it is when i first
started on the trading floor
i thought it was chaos right and most
people when they see the picture of the
trading floor it's chaos you know i
think that's why cnbc you know
they still love to take pictures of the
trading floor and you know have people
talk from the trading floor because it
looks like so you know it's
so busy so chaotic but it's it's really
not it's very organized you know who
you're
signaling to in the pits everything is
very organized
and the same thing with orderful it's
actually very organized once you
understand
what you're looking at so again you know
average traders they just look at a
normal bar chart right they don't see
what's happening in the market
they just see the price that traded so
take it a step further
right and have software that's going to
show you who's in control of the market
so you know where buyers are getting
stronger or weaker
they'll show you areas where the market
is potentially reversing
and so much more you know advanced
i don't you know orderful traders view
the market this way but you could
become more of an advanced order flow
trader by having software that's going
to show you um
areas where you know there's market
generated support or resistance you know
or there's
a lot of aggressive buying you know or
there's market rejection
you know and again you know this is the
order for trader software is just
telling you you know
in this bar there's strong support in
here that's this green area
strong support in here that's this green
area right as the market is going up
you know as the market's going up you
don't really think of support
but in order flow that's an important
concept right of understanding that
there's
support coming into the market as the
market's rallying
because as the market is rallying you
also you don't want to just see
new higher prices being made of course
you do but you also want to see
supportive buying coming in
people holding up the market as well in
case they're selling that's going to
come in it's going to hit that support
that's in the market
and it's going to stop right that
support is going to hold up the market
and then keep going up and up so as the
market is rallying if you see
market generated support come in that's
good sign right as it's still going up
you see more
market generate support that's a good
sign right
and everybody always talks about
you know let your winners run and cut
your losses short and they
really think that it's just about having
a tight stop it's not you know
that just gets you stopped out a lot
more it's about understanding what's
happening in the market so if conditions
change you could get out
early but if you're in a position how
you're going to let it run more
if you can't read the market right if
you understand that yeah i'm along and
then i see supportive buying coming in
that's a bullish sign you can stay in
the trade longer because now you have an
area
of support as the market's rallying
right you have an
area you can hide behind rather than
just arbitrarily
throwing in a take profit somewhere
because you know it markets going up
right but if you see that support coming
in the market you could feel more
confident
on letting your winning trade run
but again you know if you're looking at
a normal bar chart like this
right you're coming down into the low
this red line is the low of the day
you're wondering what what's the market
going to do next right you know we just
had that big bar down
you know then we went sideways we
started coming back down to it but if
you're looking at a footprint chart in
order flow chart
you're going to be able to see so much
more information right you can see
okay well we came down we came down
within you know a couple ticks of it but
now there's a lot of aggressive buying
right you can see it's got nice positive
strong positive delta that's growing
right you're seeing imbalances in the
bar right you're seeing
points of control move higher so you
know if
you you can i don't say safely by this
but you could have a high confidence
that yeah this low is going to hold
and you could get long based on what's
happening in the market
so you know order flows trader 3.0
software
or actually you know it really takes the
information you see in the time and
sales and depth of market
and puts it into an easy to read format
right you really
want to understand what's happening in
the market now this is a difference okay
this chart
versus this is a normal footprint chart
that just shows you your delta
your imbalances your points of control
in the bar this is an order flows trader
3.0 chart
and down here right you're seeing the
value area
right of a bar right you're seeing um
highlighted points of controls that
matter you're seeing a bar highlighted
that has a lot of imbalances as opposed
to just
you know one or two imbalances so you're
seeing a lot of bullish activity coming
in
right off this low so that's why i talk
about you know when you take a high
confidence trade
that you know this buying it off the low
now again it's not trying to predict the
low
you're really just reading the order
flow and the order flow's telling you
yeah you know what based off of what's
coming into the market and trading
in the market as opposed to what people
are showing in the order book
you could make a more uh confident
decision
in your trading to get long right
because you know the best place to buy
with the most profit opportunity
is off the low of the day so if you have
reasons
that are valid to be buying off the low
of the day it's going to give you a
great trading opportunity
okay and this is that low down here
right
and you know if you're using moving
averages your average would sort of come
down in here your view app
you know you'd be looking around
somewhere around 765
but the signs in the overflow are
happening down here in the 30 area the
40 area right if you're getting long up
in here at 6570
well you just missed this nice move up
here i mean there's more to the move
here
but really the order flow gets you into
the trades
quicker right rather than waiting for
your your lagging indicator
to trigger right you're based off oh
okay
we're at the low but i see what was
happening in the order flow
and it's a great buying opportunity okay
and to take advantage of it
so again you know bar charts just show
the price that traded but that's just
the starting point right
overflow chart shows the price traded
and volume traded
but more importantly the volume traded
on the bid and the volume traded on the
offer
okay so again you know what would you
rather have just going oh i know where
the high and the low
of the bar is where the bar opened and
closed or knowing exactly what the
volume was that traded
now again it's not about trying to
analyze every single tick that comes
through what you're looking for
is you're looking for those special
instances where
things are so clear so dominant in the
order flow
right that it just you just can't miss
it right it's like
so obvious it just appears right before
you right it's not about analyzing well
8 traded here against 61 what does that
mean in 71 against once
what does that mean no it's like okay
it's gonna
you'll see i'll show you examples you
know of things that are just so obvious
just stick out so much
that you know to not take the trade
you'd be
you know you'll look back to god that
was so obvious
so markets trade in a two-way auction
okay
there's a bid which is the buyers and
there are our offers right which are the
sellers
and people who work bids and work offers
are called passive traders now for a
trade to happen
a trader needs to either buy the offer
or a trader needs to sell the bid you
know they need to cross the bid offer
line and when a trader does that
he's considered the aggressor you know
these are called aggressive traders
and order flow is going to help you
understand what the passive traders are
doing
and what the aggressive traders are
doing right because you know
you really want to be following what the
big traders are doing you know
because they're the ones that have the
money that are going to move the market
so if you see
big aggressive traders coming into the
market and you're gonna try and fight
them well
nine times out of ten you're going to
lose right you know the saying is
in life it applies to trading as well if
you can't beat them join them
right if you're not going to be goldman
sachs so you might as well join what
they're doing
right again you know traders used to pay
hundreds of thousands of dollars to be
on the trading floor when there were
um you know many trading floors all
around the world now there's just you
know one or two
and reason being so they can see the
order flow that's coming into the market
you know what people are trading
now again time and sales gives you all
that information but it moves too
fast right you can't make any sense of
it
now in case you've ever wondered you
know why it's different colors is
because
you know if it's green
or red you know it's telling you the
what the aggressive traders are doing
right it's not just saying well you know
in the old days it used to just print
the price but now
it shows you know depending on the color
if it's
red or orange in this case you know it's
someone that's
selling the bid right whereas if it's
green it's someone that's buying the
offer
but you could take that information all
this information you're seeing traded
here
on this time in sales you could put it
into a nice easy to read format
right that's why you know the people
that created the footprint chart
were really in my opinion pioneers right
because it's like all this information
that's out there you take that and put
it into
an easy to read formats right the
footprint chart
and when you organize the data based on
how it's traded you have
more data points to analyze right you
have delta which is a difference between
aggressive buying and aggressive selling
you have points of control
right which is the difference between
sorry this point of control is the price
level in the bar with the most volume
and you have imbalances right where
aggressive buyers outnumber aggressive
sellers
by a fixed ratio usually it's four to
one but you could use whatever you want
or vice versa
but why is this important is because
it's going to give you more
insight into what's happening right now
in the market
right delta is generally negative
as the market is selling off you can see
the negative deltas right
minus 54 minus 67 minus 221 minus 71
minus 31 minus
70 minus 50 minus 113. as the market
starts to rally
it's positive 593 45 428
209. why is because as the market's
selling off you have
people hitting the bid you know
aggressively when the market's rallying
they're lifting the offer that's why you
have positive delta on moves up
generally and negative delta on moves
down
now the point of control is the price
level in the bar with the most volume no
fancy calculation it's just
you take the volume traded on the bid at
a price and the volume traded on the
offer and the price and if that price
level
has the most volume that's what's
considered the point of control
okay every bar is going to have one
and generally as prices you know as the
market is moving down
point of control is going to migrate
lower lower lower
lower then as you go sideways point of
controls generally
sort of line up you know around the same
area not necessarily at the same
level but you know within you know one
or two price levels usually
see one these two are same this one's
one tick higher this one's about
two ticks lower but as the market starts
going up point of control
starts moving higher higher higher
higher higher
okay so this because people are happy to
transact
at those higher levels as the market is
moving up
now imbalances all right imbalances are
a sign
of aggressive trading and you often see
them
in trends okay
and not every bar is going to have
imbalances because again it's based on
what's happening in the two-way auction
and it's based on the volume right it's
a ratio it's a percentage rather um you
know
four to one so as you can see here this
is a selling of balance it's 30 traded
on the bid versus five on the offer
it was 29 against seven generally most
of the volume is pretty evenly
distributed
in a bar right it's you know you will
have more
on a bid sometimes or more on the offer
but when it starts getting
out of sort of the normal parameters
again which is usually about four to one
some people use ten to one some people
use five to one
some people even use three to one okay
when it starts
moving um away from sort of you know the
normal
three to one two to one one to one
ratios then you start considering that
an imbalance
okay it's like a tug of war right you
have people that are equal strength
but if you have five guys on one team
and 30 guys on another obviously the
side with 30 guys is going to win
right that's your imbalance there and
it's the same as markets move down you
generally see selling imbalances
which are the red numbers in a bar as
markets move up you've seen
blue numbers in the bar right as opposed
to the black numbers is just your normal
order flow
okay now again you know just
just reiterate drive the point home
buying and balances occur
when what's traded on the offer is
four times more than what's traded on
the bid all right selling it balances is
the opposite when there's
more traded on the bid than trading on
the offer by you know four to one
you can see 18 against four 27 against
zero 27 against five
um 28 against five right these red
numbers are selling and balances
these blue numbers are buying and
balances the black numbers in the bar
that's just your normal order flow okay
right just buying and balances blue
numbers
in the bar right simple right keep it
simple it's not about making trading
complicated
it's about understanding what's
happening in the market
so again as the market's moving up
you're seeing the buying imbalances
buying and balance buying imbalances
this market starts moving down a little
bit selling it balances because
aggressive you know traders are
aggressive
as the market's moving up you know
people want to get on board they're
aggressive
as the market hits a high people you
know think okay now it's time to take
profits so they start hitting the bids
you know getting out getting out
right as the market goes sideways
now with imbalances you also have this
thing called stacked imbalances so if
you have
you know three or more imbalances in a
row and stack neatly on top of each
other here's one two three four
five six actually but you know most
people will start it at three
just look for three or more that's you
know that's something
that's called the stacked imbalance and
it acts as support or resistance
in the market and if it's a stack buying
it support it's a stack selling
imbalance it would be considered um
resistance
right so selling it balances again it's
the red numbers in the bar
right you can see in here 34 against 3
19 against 3 42 against 6 86 against 14.
right as the markets move down you
generally see
majority of selling imbalances now
that's not to say that there won't be
buying and balances on a move down
because you know there's always people
trading right two-way auctions you know
as the market's moving down sometimes
big traders that's a great buying
opportunity or they want to take their
profits or whatever
so that's why you do see some buying and
balances but overall on moves down
you're seeing the stack
i'm sorry you're seeing the selling
imbalances
okay now a stacked selling imbalance
again is the opposite of a stack buying
a balance
there's three or more selling imbalances
stacked neatly on top of each other
and again it's going to act as
resistance right as you can see here you
got your stack selling and balance
and basically the cause of it is there's
a big trader comes in just hits all the
bids boom boom boom
right mark comes back up you know maybe
they reappear start selling some more
and the market continues down
so having all that order flow
information is nice right but
you know it helps you see how the market
is traded
as a trader you want to know how to use
that information to take trades you know
that's the whole point right so you want
to get the most out of order flow
this is saying right we've all heard the
saying you know when life hands you
lemons you make lemonade right and in
trading it's a similar thought the
market hands you a lot of information
what are you going to do with it nothing
no you use it to your advantage right
you take advantage of all that
information
and why wouldn't you use that
information you know to be honest
institutional traders hedge funds big
traders are all using some aspects of
order flow
right in reality there's an arms race
going on
at the institutional level to take all
the information that's generated from
the market
and i don't say mine it but you know
find useful bits of information
that they could put into their trading
system their algo
to take advantage of it right because
really what order flow is
it's the most up-to-date information of
what's happening in the market right
gone are the days of just relying on
on what price is doing sure you can
still trade price action
um you know but why just limit yourself
is what i'm saying is you know expand
your
territory so to speak you know your
repertoire
on adding more information
that's going to help you as a trader
right because that's really what you
want to do right
you want to know when the really big
traders
are active and busy in the market right
you know the guys that sit around in the
offices
pork bellies you know you know
from trading places but you know like
the the
the big traders when they're active in
the market you want to know so you can
also
participate either one trade in the same
direction or two
get out of the way right you don't want
to be
standing in front of a you know a trader
that's got 5000 e-minis to buy over the
next 15 minutes
because generally you're going to get
run over
you know what causes markets to go up or
down is the aggressive traders
right for the most part aggressive
traders control the immediate direction
of the market
you know so how can you see aggressive
trading well it appears in the time and
sales but who wants to look at the time
and sales all day
right the easiest way is to look for
imbalances
in the order flow now you got to
understand
markets have different conditions right
you have normal market conditions and
you have trending market conditions
or what i like to refer to it as flow
driven market
in a normal rotating market like the
order flow is normal
right that's what's to be expected in a
normal market but in a flow driven
market you see clues the big traders are
active and moving the market
here's a normal market condition it's
just going sideways you're seeing some a
little bit of aggressive buying a little
bit aggressive selling
delta is kind of neutral so aggressive
traders are pretty equal
all right again more normal market
activity just back and forth right up
you know trading in a tight range
but when the market starts coming out of
those ranges you know what are you going
to see you're going to see sellers
dominating if the market is selling off
right what are you going to see you're
going to see a lot of selling of
balances
you're going to see a lot a strong
negative delta as the market's selling
off right
you want to know when the sellers are
dominating
or when the buyers are dominating right
here's
buyers dominating as the market is
shooting up
off the lows of the day okay sellers
dominating right as the market is just
falling off a cliff boom boom boom
you're seeing a lot of selling
imbalances
seeing stack selling imbalances you're
seeing strong negative delta
very little aggressive buying happening
right
so you know that's how order flow is
really going to help you
in that sense right it's going to tell
you when the aggressive traders are
active
right and as the quicker you can pick it
up
you know when the aggressive traders are
active in the market the better off
your trading results are going to be
so market nuances right that's the
beauty of order flow it's going to help
you see all these little market nuances
right
and you know one of my favorite is the
market sweep
right you know sweep the leg johnny you
know that that's
in the karate kid right that's what uh
chris told johnny on how to win the
point the next point is
sweep the leg and in tr you know
in the old days of when electronic
training first started out
there was a feature on the nymex comic
system
um to sweep the markets right normally
you just
you know if the market is six bit at
seven all right you just
buy everything up to nine or something
right that would be a sweep but they
actually had a feature on on this
on the old system to sweep the market
you know so you could just enter your
quantity
and it would just sweep everything in
there and you know we used to joke you
know
you know when someone would was about to
do a sweep they're going to say i'm
going to sweep the leg
but you know what it a sweep is all it
is is
when a trader takes out several price
levels in one trade
okay so a buy sweep occurs when a trader
buys everything up to a certain level
right so in this case right the market
is
41.25 bid at 25 and a quarter
okay so the traders thinking well then i
think this market's going to higher
and or they want to move the market
higher they're going to put an
order in they're not going to buy the
25s and then see how it reacts and then
buy
the 50s and then by the three quarters
notice i think this market's going
higher
um i'm going to buy 300 right now up to
26 right so they're going to instantly
lift all these offers
and turn it bit here so it's going to be
26 bit at 26 and a quarter
that's a sweep right basically they're
clearing out all the offers
okay so that's a buy sweep now a sell
sweep
you know is the opposite right it occurs
when a aggressive seller comes in and
thinks the market's going to go lower
so in this case you know it's 25 25 and
a quarter
but he's like i think this market's
going i think this number is going to
come in negative i'm going to queue this
up to
to sweep everything down to 24. you know
so they'll put in
sell 1000 at 24 and they'll get this 96
the 121 the 153
the 200 the 241 and
if they're not filled yet you know
they'll be working an offer at
24 here right and then sellers will come
in and fill in these
um offers in here now if there's a big
iceberg in here say someone's got
um a thousand to buy here at 24 and
three quarters but only showing you know
a hundred
if he comes in trying to sweep
everything down to
it's only gonna stop here at 24 and a
quarter because there's a big ice if
there was a big iceberg here it would
basically it would absorb his whole
order okay
and again you know that that's another
little nuances sometimes sweeps
run into iceberg orders that are sitting
in the book because we don't know where
iceberg orders are
right until the trades you don't know if
there's an iceberg order going to be
refreshing until it starts to trade
there
now for a sweep to be effective right
and move the market
there needs to be a lack of resting
liquidity right or
else the sweep is is going to be
absorbed like i said if there's an
iceberg order
if you're trying to sell everything down
to 24 but there's a big iceberg here at
24 and three quarters
you're just going to sell everything in
into 24 and three quarters and be filled
and it's still going to be 24 and
three-quarter bid
right and that you know as a trader is
another nuance right that you can take
advantage of and again on a normal
candlestick or bar chart you're not
going to know where sweeps occur
right on a footprint chart if you know
what to look for
right now i know where there are sweeps
on here i can see there's by a sweep
right in here
obviously a sweep up here but again you
have to know what to look for
in the market and in the order flow and
that's why
um you know do these trainings to sort
of you know
instruct you right so basically what
you're looking for
is where price jumps several price
levels with no counter trade
so if the market is trading 25 at 25 and
a quarter
90 on the bid 20 on the offer then all
of a sudden
you turn away then you look back all of
a sudden it's 26 26 and a quarter
often times if someone just came in and
swept all these offers and turned it bid
here
right and if you're looking at a
footprint chart
you can see where the sweeps are sweep
here sweep here
sweep here okay and
again the reason why i talk about the
order flows trader software is because
we have a function on there
a sweep detector to highlight areas um
where sweeps occur in the market right
if you're looking at a bar chart you
can't see that there's a sweep in here
right you could guess that maybe there's
a sweep in this big bar here but
you don't know for certain you know you
could sort of guess
by looking at this chart because oh you
know it's a big bar down so there's a
lot of aggressive selling
maybe coming someone came in and swept
the order book but you don't know
on a footprint chart if you know what to
look for yeah you can you can see it i
know there's a sweep card here
but you know it's nice to have software
that's going to show that to you
you know you have it right here now
sometimes i'll be honest sometimes
stacked imbalances
overlap sweeps but not always
right so you can see actually the sweep
was up here
right if you're looking at stacked
imbalances you can see a stacked
imbalance here
stacked in balance here right most order
flow traders are taught to look for
stacked imbalances
one here one here okay
but if you're looking at sweeps you can
notice there was a sweep up here
well before the stacked selling
imbalance right so where would you
rather be short from
up in here at 64.00 or short down here
at 63.85 after the sweep occurred
right you like of course you'd want to
be short from 64.00
where the first sweep occurred and
that's the real power of
of you know order flow is going to help
you that's just one little nuance
now another thing i'll talk about is
order flow sequencing okay
waterfall sequencing occurs when
the resting liquidity is stacked and
taken out now what do i mean by stacked
okay well what i mean is subsequent
um higher amounts of volume on the offer
or on the bids as you're going down on
the bids or going up on the offer
right oftentimes the book is not usually
stacked
neatly like this right it's often
stacked like
you know 96 and 121 and then
you know 100 and then back to 200 and
then back to 185
but when big traders right when big
traders are
trying to work their way out of position
you know try to finesse their way out of
a position take profits
you know the market is say the market
had been selling off
okay it's coming down to 25 they're
saying okay just you know
i'm happy to get out now just get me out
you know worst price 25. okay so you
know
they'll work some 25s they'll work more
at 24 and three-quarters more at 24 and
a half
um you know some at 24 and a quarter
some at 24. right they'll stack their
order book right they'll
they'll work subsequently higher amounts
of bids they're not going to just buy
everything at 25.
no they're gonna finesse it in there
trying to get a better fill you know if
they're happy to get out at 25 people
say well you just work everything at 25
well
if you know institutional traders you
know they
they want everything better right they
don't want just yeah yeah it's worst
price 25 you don't think that
okay well you feel that 25 you're like
well they're trading 24 and a half i
didn't get anything there
you know they'll yell at you and call
you every curse word in the book
so what they do you know is they work
some at 25 a little more at 24 and three
quarters
in case it starts ticking down right
they're getting better fills right so
then when the execution trader goes back
to the trader
yeah you know i got you i bought you
your thousand averages uh 24.6
okay okay great thank you like that so
that's what a stacked order book looks
like
but having a stacked order book is one
thing right
it has to trade that resting liquidity
volume okay
now on a footprint chart you can see it
right but then you really got to analyze
the chart right and i'll be honest i
don't like sitting there staring at
all the numbers myself that's why in the
software we created
the order flow sequencing to tell me
that there was
you know as this market's going up
you're seeing the sequencing occur
right bullish you know the green
happening on the offer so
subsequently higher offers are being
taken out then you get up here to
sort of your inflection point right
where the market turns now you're seeing
the order flow sequencing the bearish
sequencing coming in
after you hit a swing high right which
is bearish right as the market's going
up yeah that's what you like to see
but then as you start market goes down
right you're starting to see the bearish
sequencing right and it's a tool to help
you keep you in a trade right i was
talking about earlier is
um letting your profits run right that's
what these tools
help you to do right let if you're in a
trade say well
i'm still i'm still long okay there's
some boiler sequencing boiler sequencing
and boiler sequencing
then you see the bearish order flow
sequencing okay you know that's a sign
that you could probably start cutting
your position right and you see some
more
okay you know you should cut out of it
already
so let your software right that's why i
talk about the order flows trader
software is we have this function in
there to show you to highlight that to
you
right and as you can see right as the
market is going up right before it takes
off you see the bullish sequencing
coming in
right you're still in the trade oh
there's some boiler sequencing still
happening here
yeah i could let it run a bit uh oh
bearish okay so you can't start thinking
covering it now
okay again
bearish sequencing boom market sells off
hits that inflection point the turning
point
right whereas buying starts to come in
and you're seeing bullish sequencing
bullish sequencing bullish sequencing
as the market goes back up
again more sequencing bullish sequencing
here here here
bearish bullish bullish bullish bearish
as the market right before it drops off
right you see that bearish sequencing
come in
it's a file as a apple chart right but
we hit the low of the day
bullish sequencing right as the market
starts moving back up
as you hit the high of the day looks
like it's going sideways but you're
seeing the bearish sequencing right
before the market sells off
jp morgan all right you're at your low
of the day okay bearish sequencing
that's what you expect to see
but now here you made a new low but
you've seen bullish sequencing
right before the market shoots straight
up in a 45 degree line
now on some markets you know like tesla
where
sort of you know there's a lot of space
in between trades
it's not going to really be very
effective because there's just not
enough trades right orderful looks at
volume so if you don't have a lot of
volume it's just not going to be very
effective
right you want stocks that you know
trading um
very tight bid offer you know not five
cent bid offers
like you know tesla 10 cents bid offers
okay so the last part i talked about is
discovering trading opportunities that
other traders miss okay now
the reason i talk about overflow trader
trader software in the beginning is
because i want you to see how easy
reading the order flow can be
to show you who's in control of the
market to be in sync
with the market right understand why the
market stops and reverses
so we always you know software is
developed
to help us in life you know whether it's
windows and even though people will
people argue windows is helpful or not
but you know tools like microsoft
offices to help us you know photo
editing
software is to help us and training
software should be the same way that's
where i created the order flows trader
software 3.0
right because i want to see areas where
there's market exhaustion
where there's market weakness where
their support and resistance
where their sweeping activity where
there's market imbalances
i want to see where the immediate value
areas where there's aggressive trading
and so much more i mean there's
so much information out there available
to a trader that
you know to not use it really is
got has me scratching my head you know
sometimes i talk to traders
and they'll send me a chart and i'll be
like well why did you buy here like well
you know my moving average this one
crossed over that one i'm like okay but
where were the aggressive buyers were
there aggressive buyers coming in
as you know it's one thing to use moving
averages you can but if you
if you use it in conjunction with order
flow and you say okay yeah
i got aggressive buyers coming in it's
going to give you a more effective trade
so market exhaustion you know really
what is market exhaustion is when the
last buyer
has bought or the last seller has sold
and on an individual bar you can see
that
right you can see where the last seller
has sold in a bar
right if there's going to be exhaustion
in the bar or if it's just going to be
normal order flow
and the order flows trader will
highlight to you at the bottom of bars
if there's
signs of market exhaustion you can see
this green area here here
right as you're coming down this market
exhaustion here
right off this low here here as the
market's going up now you're seeing
bullish sign you're seeing bullish
sequencing
seeing a bullish poc here and you're
seeing market exhaustion market
exhaustion
so these are all tools to help keep you
in the trade
longer all right here's another example
of market exhaustion right
as the market's going up you're seeing
the lower prices as the market is going
up
a sign of you know exhaustion is
actually a sign of
rejection the lower prices are being
rejected here
right just as the higher price you know
as the market is the high came off
starts to rally
this higher price right here on this
move up is being rejected
okay market sells off a little bit now
market starts moving higher
as you're going up it keeps you know
makes that new high
test the high starts to come off but
those lower prices on the move
up are being rejected right this again
that's a bullish
sign now another thing i'll talk about
is
market weakness right and market
weakness is a tremendous piece of
information to a trader
right it's like your fuel gauge on your
car right you know do i still have gas
or do i need to refill gas right and
think of it like a move
is a move running out of gas or or not
basically is it move higher running out
of gas going up
or does it move down running out of gas
as it's going down
right so there are two types of market
weakness there's bearish market weakness
and it occurs when the market has been
moving higher but can't sustain the move
any
higher than buying and why not it's
because the buying is weakening
now a bullish market weakness is kind of
an oxymoron but you don't think of
bullish
being weak but really what it is it's
the market has been going
lower and lower but the selling is
getting weaker and weaker
all right it's just the selling just
sort of starts tapering off
and it eventually is exhausted right the
selling is weakening
so how can you see it well bullish
market weakness again
watch the delta okay because the selling
is weakening
what is happening in the delta right is
it getting stronger is it getting weaker
is it doing nothing
right the market has been going down but
the sellers are getting less and less
until finally the buyers take control of
the market
and bearish market weakness is the
opposite right a market has been going
up and up
but the buying is weakening until
there's no more
aggressive buyers right and if there's
no more aggressive buyers in the market
what's going to happen to the market
well there's nobody lifting the offers
right so the market's not going to go
any higher
so watch the deltas right is the
aggressive buying getting stronger or
weaker
as the market keeps going up so here's a
sign of of market weakness right
market went up off the low this red line
is the low
then just sort of went sideways right
but it's not sustaining that move
right even though we have some bullish
signs here in the market which is good
right you're thinking well this market
can go up
but if you're watching the delta you're
seeing delta's you know the aggressive
selling
i'll say the aggressive buying is
getting weaker right 400
delta 300 right 27 that's not a good
sign
right for this market to be moving up
keep moving up it's got to be
stronger delta you know it's got to go
600 600 you know
instead it's getting weaker right it's
gone from 400 so you have
400 more aggressive buyers and sellers
to only 300
and then 27 it might as well be zero
basically you know it is very weak then
obviously
aggressive selling comes in and the
market sells off and starts making new
lows
now here's a bullish market weakness
right market's selling off nicely right
boom boom boom you get down here but the
selling
is getting weaker right it's gone 58
minus 3
75 minus 42 minus 39 it's getting weaker
as the market is going down
and then it turns buyers right buyers
step up and you're seeing aggressive
buying come
in 46 7 8 23 14.
right but software having software
that's going to highlight that to you
like this blue arrow or this orange
arrow
is just going to put you make your
trading life so much easier
now the the next one i'll talk about is
imbalances right but not just
i talked about general imbalances before
i talked about stacked imbalances but i
want to talk about now is multiple
imbalances okay and it's like having a
you know i've got kids right and
everybody wants equal amounts of stuff
you know it's like one kid gets a
two toys the other kids only got one
well why does she get two
i only got one i want another one and
you know there's imbalances right
i mean even though this trade happening
left and right you know
is it balanced or is it out of balance
okay
now stacked in balance you know
imbalances when you have one
imbalance obviously between the bid and
the offer stacked imbalances when you
have
three or more imbalances stacked on top
of each other
neatly right now multiple imbalances is
when you have
three or more imbalances spread out
through the bar
okay so you can see here's one two three
four
five six okay
the order flows trader software puts a
nice box around it
okay and it's not just about trading
every bar that has multiple imbalances
right
use your brain and i hated that i had a
boss that would you always say that
use your brain you know it would always
be like
uh i am but you know really
what he's saying is think about what you
know what you're seeing
right you're coming into a low you're
seeing
multiple imbalances that's what you
expect to see you're
at your low but now you're seeing
multiple buying imbalances
what do you think that's a good sign or
a bad sign well that's a very strong
sign it's telling you the aggressive
buyers are appearing
at the low of the day right that's going
to give you a nice trading opportunity
you know when people talk about trading
in context that's what trading in
context means
okay again you're taking out the highs
you're seeing buying imbalances that's
where you expect to see buying
imbalances
up here when you're taking out the highs
but once you hit the high
and you start coming off if you see
multiple selling imbalances
one two three then you know that hey
aggressive sellers are coming in here
they think that this is a good area to
sell
right over here you've got multiple
selling of balances
okay fine but really the bar to be
trading it off of is this one right
closer to the high
of the day that's this green line again
take it in market context right you want
to be selling after
you know the market sold off from 75
down to 70.
or do you want to be taking it right
after the market made that new high and
you see the aggressive sellers coming in
so i talk about when i say order flow
gets you as close to the market gives
you the freshest information out there
now the next part i want to talk about
is value area
right and value area if if you're
familiar with market profile volume
profile
volume the value area of the profile is
where 70 percent of the volume
occurs in the trading day right and
you can actually break it down on a bar
by bar basis now
you know think about it value right a
lot of traders don't trade
around value they don't recognize where
the value is but it's like buying a
house
okay and it's a crazy market right now
okay
and people buy a house sometimes they're
paying over the valuation
right they're paying more than the house
is worth well
you know as a trader you don't want to
be paying more than the house is worth i
mean
obviously unless you need a place to
stay unless you're so
aggressive right that you i need this
house i love this house for whatever
reason i need a house
so i don't want to miss out so i'm going
to give more but generally the way most
people do you know like you watch house
hunters or
all these shows on tv to make house
hunting so easy like oh you look at
three houses go eat an ice cream
put a bid in 20 000 below the offering
price and buy it
right it doesn't work that way really
what you want to do ideally
is buy the house below value
or as close to value without going over
it right and as traders
you know you should always be cognizant
of where the value
is in the market and you could break it
down on a bar by bar basis
okay and the order flows trader software
does that
it puts a box in the bar
where the value area is and it really
opens up a
whole form of analysis right because now
you can see
gaps in the value right as the market
starts
trending you're going to see gaps like
in this case you're trending down you're
seeing gaps in the value between this
bar and this bar
gaps in value between this bar and this
bar right as the market is
moving lower right as the market's
moving higher you're going to see gaps
like this
but then you don't see anything you just
see overlapping value when you see value
overlapping it's a sign of a sideways
market right then you're going to look
for those breakaway gaps here
here as the market starts selling off
then of course you could add in things
like sequencing
things like multiple imbalances etc
and it's going to just it really just
puts you over the top as a trader right
gets you to the top of
mount everest now even with value areas
there's
certain value areas that are even
more bullish or bearish than other ones
and that's
we're having good software to highlight
that to you like this
in this case this is a very bearish uh
value area it colors it this red color
so you can
take advantage of that right you can get
short right to take advantage of this
move down again value areas right if
every bar has a value area but some
value areas are going to be more bullish
or bearish than others
right and having software that's going
to highlight that to you
it's going to just put you ahead of
everybody else right you see this is a
those blue color value area is very
bullish
now there's so much more information
available from order filtrate than from
order flow
that traders even realize right
unfortunately there's not enough time to
discuss it all today i really i've gone
over an hour already
um and i could really go on all day long
so you know the one thing i want you to
keep in mind is don't just trade the
market blindly
trade it in context of what's happening
at all times right you just can't trade
anything blindly
right you put things in context right
and
a plain old footprint chart with you
know your imbalances
with your point of control with your
delta is a great place to start right a
lot of training platforms
give you a footprint chart right if you
really want to learn how to
how to use a footprint chart go to my
youtube channel
there's i've got tons of videos on on
how to read a plain footprint chart you
know it's very helpful even if you just
learned one or two things
today you know that you could apply to
your footprint chart that's great
but why just limit yourself to that
right why not get software that's going
to take
that information you're seeing on your
footprint chart
and highlight certain things to you
highlight market weakness highlight
support resistance
highlight sweeping activity highlight
market imbalance highlight
value areas highlight aggressive trading
and and so much more
right take that information that you see
on
the time and sales and put it into your
brain right in an
easy to use formats right
don't make trading more difficult than
than it has to be
make it easier right and that's where
having software
is going to help you it's going to put
you so far ahead of everybody else
now there's two ways to do things right
the easy way the hard way
which do you prefer well me i prefer the
path of least resistance
i let the computer show me what's
happening in the market that's why i
created
orderflows.com is the software
right it was the software i created to
make my own trading easier
but then people i started talking to
people and they're seeing it like hey
you know can you sell it to me like well
you know
at first that really wasn't my intention
my intention was just to improve the
software that i had
right to make my trading a lot easier
so in this past hour hopefully you'll
agree it's been time that's been well
spent but again i can't cover everything
in a 60-minute training session right
but i got a special offer for you so you
get everything
you need to know about order flow and if
you act fast it'll give you a very
special deal
right because again you know i
appreciate the time that you've taken
for watching this presentation
so you're going to be thrilled right i
hope you'll be thrilled right because
this is a great deal
right you're going to get the order
flows trader software 3.0
it's for ninjatrader 8 okay now it will
work on the free version of ninjatrader
it'll work on the paid version of
ninjatrader
so for example if you have a trading
platform from another broker
like say you're using amp you know and
you have sierra chart
but you want to use the order flows
trader software you can get
my software get the free version of
ninjatrader
install my software on it you just need
a data feed of course a real-time data
feed
and you could use it as a charting
platform and just execute your trades
on another platform okay so for example
i trade
markets overseas but i get data from the
data provider
and i just execute on a broker's front
end okay
and what the order flows trader 3.0 is
it's the volume footprint chart
with 17 pre-programmed order flow tools
i talked about a few market suite market
weakness
obviously in balanced value area etc but
you get
17 pre-programmed order flow tools in
there
and it's very easy to set up right you
don't need templates
anything right i i even explained it to
you how to set it up right it really
just takes a couple of minutes to set
everything up
normally i sell it for 8.99 on my
website you go there right now buy it
for 8.99
and really what the order flows trader
3.0 is it takes everything that you
see that or everything that's happening
in the order flow
and puts it into a program so you can
see what the institute institutionals
traders are doing in the market right
it's like hooking my brain up to the
computer
right but having the software is one
thing right
you need to know how to use it and
i've bought software and it's really
difficult to understand how to use it
sometimes you know it's like
you feel like you need to understand
programming in order to know how to use
it
and i don't like that right i want to be
able i want something easy
and that was a big thing with me because
you know yeah i'm
very computer literate i'm not a
programmer and i wanted something that
was easy to use
right and i i understand order flow but
i you know i know you
on the other end of this presentation
you know you may be new to order flow
okay and i want to make the learning
curve
as short as possible so i give you a lot
of education
on how to trade with the order flow i'll
give you access for free
to my order flows trading course right
it's a 20 lesson
course it's about 15 hours of video
instruction
and you know it's a great starting point
for learning order flow right and
normally i sell this for 297 on my
website you're going to get it for free
today
but more importantly you know i said you
know today's training is more for
advanced traders
and if you take advantage of this deal
you're going to get access to my
inner circle video series which is 56
videos on advanced order flow
i don't want to use the term tricks but
you know tips
nuances and analysis you know it's a
great way to expand your
overflow knowledge so you start adding
it up
the software the training the inner
circle video series
you know it's it's close to seventeen
hundred dollars you know sixteen ninety
three
but it's one thing to learn from videos
and books
it takes discipline takes commitment but
what i found
very helpful to traders is live training
right where you can ask questions right
sort of one
it's not one-on-one but it's a group
right and for the last
over two years now i've been hosting
live user training sessions
um for all users to join where i drive
home what i saw in the overflow the past
week
you can ask questions about areas you
were struggling with your order flow
you know even questions about the
software i can help you out there
and i do it every tuesday night between
7 pm and 8 pm central time
there's an archive so if you can't watch
or attend
you can watch the replay there's over
120 episodes in there
right and and some of these gurus out
there they want to charge you
extra on how to use their software and
what to look for
but i give you this for free right i
i don't understand why you know people
sell you software then they want to sell
you
on how to use it right that should be
part of the cost
right i mean i hate that but you know
that's
how some people are so you add all that
up it's almost
two thousand dollars right it's 1893. i
mean i honestly i can't even put a price
on the
live weekly training you know i just put
it down as 200 because i've seen other
vendors
out there selling it for 200 a month
right it's just crazy
but it's just a one-time payment of 7.49
there's no monthly recurring payments or
any other payment in the future
now you will have to pay you know your
data fees that's a monthly fee
it doesn't go to me goes to the data
provider and obviously your ninja
trader fee if you're going to use a paid
version a ninjatrader
but it's just a one-time payment you
know i i hate these things where
you know they like well you know we're
going to charge you 99
a month and then you know you're
basically going to be paying it for the
rest of your life you know
you you try to cancel it um and and you
just can't cancel it
right it's just it's one of those things
where like you got to cancel your credit
card
in order to cancel your your payments
right and i hate that right that's why
it's just a one-time payment right but
you know
there's a lot of users out there they're
saying great things about this order
flow trader software right i mean
sheila says you know your order
illustrator software is remarkably
helpful because i can clearly see now
what's really happening in the market
you know for example who's in control
of the market on a very specific time
and who's getting weaker as well
right and then you know other comments
you know it's really if you really want
to trade properly and understand what on
earth is happening in any markets order
flow is the path forward
and with mike's experience and
explanation it clicks
so what you do i put the link in the
chat already
go to orderflows.com
scroll down this page okay this is what
it looks like there's a videos
introduction video
scroll down that page there's a button
here
click this button get started right
again orderflows.com3.html takes you to
paypal
paypal processes your payments i mean
everyone should be familiar with paypal
if you've ever bought anything online in
the last 20 years you're familiar with
paypal
and it's just very easy to get started
right a one-time payment of 7.49
so
right now you know you've got several
options right first option is do nothing
right now stay where you are
okay then a year from now you can watch
another one of my presentations or
videos
and realize i just wasted a year of my
life trying to
trying to do things my way and and gone
nowhere
or you can take what you've learned in
the presentation today
and go out there and try to do it on
your own nothing wrong with that
trial and error is a great way to learn
okay
but you may not realize that what you're
doing is incorrect right you're putting
the cart before the horse
okay maybe you'll see some results
maybe you won't but that's fine again
there's nothing wrong with
doing it on your own okay or the easiest
way
i take my hand and allow us to walk you
step by step
through each part of the process and
skip the trial and error
if you do the work you can see as your
life and trading
transform right before your eyes you
know put the ball in the back of the net
you know we just had the it was just the
euro championships you know
sort of joke you know england lost on on
penalty kicks and you know
the joke was well if i was england i
just kicked the ball in the back of the
net
but it's not always easy that way right
you
you need sometimes someone to help put
get the ball in the back of the net so
choose which option is best for you
option one
do nothing option two try to do it
yourself
maybe you got some success maybe not or
option three
let us let me particularly help you
you know with your order flow trading
but really you have to figure out what
motivates you in life you know
do you really want to become a better
trader or
you know is trading just something you
want to do in the part-time you know
hopefully
you want to become a successful trader
because it really opens up the doors for
you you know this is me and my family
that's what motivates me
um and for me what motivates me is
freedom
okay trading gives me that freedom it
gives me to say you know what
you know like last year during the
lockdown i want to go on vacation i'm
tired of living where we are you know
being can't go out of the store unless
you're all
wearing masks and everything and so
we're like well let's just
where can we go in the u.s well you know
south dakota
right we go there so we just piled into
the car
drove out to south dakota right if
you're working a job
something it doesn't you don't have that
freedom you you work for somebody
okay freedom to do what you want where
you want
or sometimes you know just do nothing
you know just sit on a beach and veg out
and do nothing you know that's what
training
the opportunity it gives you right gives
you that opportunity to do what you want
right and for me that's that's freedom
so figure out you know what's important
to you and for me it's my family
it's freedom to do what i want when i
want and
you know that's what motivates me now as
a special bonus
right for investors expo right for anna
for setting this up for me today i'll
give you access
to take advantage of the special package
you'll get access to the order flow
playbook as well which is normally 297
right and in it you know it's a short
course on order flow
there's probably about a dozen extra
trade setups in there
you know things you can look for in the
order flow and you'll get access to that
for free
when you take advantage of this order
flows trader 3.0 package right
again what you're going to get now is
the overflows trader 3.0
the overflow trading course the inner
circle video series
get access to the live group training as
well as those replays
and you can get access to the order
float
playbook and it's just a one-time
payment of 7.49
now if you stuck around to the end and
you want my book on
trading order flow just go to this page
order flows.com
book.html you'll have to enter your
name and email address and click submit
and it will take you to the download
page for
uh the download of the book right again
you're not going to get the hardcover
copy you're just going to get a
digital download that you could you know
download to your phone your
ipad your tablet whatever your computer
print it up or just read it
um you know on your ipad
so again get started go to
orderflows.com
off three dot html and
you know i'll end it there you know
there's
so much information in the order flow
that's available to a trader
right it it really makes no sense for
you not to use the order flow
you know people say you know what's the
one piece of advice you could give me
you know as beginning trader mike what's
the one piece of advice is understand
what's happening in the market
right if you don't understand what's
happening in the market you're going to
struggle as a trader
right you're going to be swimming
against the current so to speak
by not understanding what
flows so to speak are are happening in
the market you know
is there aggressive buying or is there
aggressive selling right you want to be
taken advantage of
the aggressive buying that's occurring
you want to be taking advantage of the
aggressive selling
if there's passive selling right how can
you take advantage of it how can you see
it more importantly
and that's what the order flow is going
to help you understand
so again to get started go to
orderflows.com
off three dot html make sure you put the
dot html on the end
and get started right because really you
know the the
the old chinese saying when's the best
time to plant a tree
it's 20 years ago and the second best
time is
right now right so you don't want to
waste any more time
right we were all on lockdown for a year
some people are still on lockdown you
know i got family that live overseas in
the countries they're in they're still
on lockdown
and i'm like well what have you done to
improve yourself well you know i've
stayed inside and done this
but they haven't really done any
self-improvement right and
really what the order flows packages
about is not just software to help your
trading
but improve you as a trader
okay so again thank you
for coming to this presentation today
and i hope to see you guys
all on the inside so bye bye everybody
you